bonjour Je vous entraîne à la découverte
de cette exposition séduction et pouvoir
l'art de s'apprêter à la cour et nous
allons commencer avec les coiffes et
coiffures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la perruque portée à la cour est
vraiment mise à la mode par le Louis XIV
souffrant d'une calvitie précoce il va
porter la perruque très jeune au départ
une perruque à trou qu'on appelait des
fenêtres pour laisser passer et mélanger
à la perruque ces mèches de vrais
cheveux et donc les courtisans vont
imiter Louis XIV assez rapidement cette
mode des perruques va se poursuivre sous
les règnes de Louis XV et de Louis XVI
mais de façon beaucoup plus modérée
à la cour de Louis XIV les usages sont
très codifiées on porte un emplâtre
blanc sur le visage on maquille de rouge
ses joues avec deux petits disques qui
sont sous les yeux et on porte sur le
visage des petites pièces de tissu en
tafta ou velours noir que l'on appelle
des mouches en le paraître à la course
et se conformer en fait il y avait
toutes sortes de normes et de codes à
respecter et les courtisans se devaient
d'appartenir à cette à ce rang de
manière très organisée et devait
respecter toutes ces règles
les courtisans portent énormément de
dentelles les hommes portent de la
dentelle vous avez ici un col magnifique
en gros point de Venise qui est vraiment
très caractéristique de ce que pouvait
porter les hommes aussi avec de Louis
XIV
[Musique]
dans le langage de la galanterie de
poche on utilise énormément l'éventail
que l'on que l'on porte à la main
ces éventails sont absolument somptueux
ils sont le fruit du travail de
plusieurs types d'artisans vous avez des
tablesiers qui réalisent les brins vous
avez les plisseuses enculeuses qui
réalisent la feuille qui a été
auparavant
peinte et dessinée par de grands
artistes ce sont les meilleurs artisans
les meilleures joaillés en fait toutes
les tous les matériaux sont les
matériaux les plus nobles toutes les
matières sont les matières les plus
précieuses donc c'est à la fois on veut
on veut vraiment paraître on veut
vraiment montrer mais tout est d'une
extrême qualité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]